turn this way that's it chin up a little
bit beautiful now hands on the hips
that's it now do me a favor you'll hide
your left hand I don't want to see it
there you go that's it beautiful and
chin up a little bit more bit more there
you go actually extend the fingers and
the thumb and like that's better and
relax it right index finger a little bit
and bring it up a little bit that's
better
okay accentuate everything that's better
perfect if don't move
Michael can you just stay closed and I
give you permission to hold on to my ass
if if if I fall yeah that's gorgeous
holiday
that's amazing
[ __ ] I know is that great yeah until
you face away and took chin down eyes
down hanging it up
all right exaggerated ash and ice dam
for specific
let's go just out your back
let me just that Bree three math that's
gorgeous hands up higher
sup
you
let's take another luck in the hand
there you got a beautiful holiday
we do this happen again
yeah it's beautiful w watch your back
one last bit
one more
come Bobby this way stop there that's it
actually do anybody do that again just
do that yeah now perfect now just bend
the arms up a little bit so like it like
that
yep don't move and just relax it and
that goes like that
yeah gorgeous darling hold it
yes beautiful double chin up got it nice
more this way bit more few more that's
it
put your hands here and cover up your
chest yeah yeah that's beautiful
gorgeous just relax you again
that's it sort of push it more out that
way rather than too much that's better
how this way
you
you
bring your right hand down stop and tilt
more if you can as much as you can and
turn your face to the right that's it
that's it hold of it
eyes down that's perfect arch your back
a little bit more beautiful blush our
promised place this way I missed your
place
she run up that's it then move all right
we got you that's it beautiful
that's better chin up sweetie chin up
more close your eyes no just looking
into her but the way you are is perfect
there all right give me a second sweetie
just waiting for the water behind you
close your eyes 1 2 open oh well let's
go straight to the pool room chin up a
bit so now close your eyes both of you
this is going to sound funny I just want
the very slightest of movement on your
faces it's almost like saying you're
loving each other just with your
foreheads are the way they're touching
bit more breathe through your mouth
they're gorgeous bit more through your
mouth more that's hitching up a little
bit turn your faces towards me a little
bit and just snuggle a little bit go for
a guy's at a hint of a smile there
that's gorgeous
and now they find spawn something
spontaneously funny
beautiful chin up a little bit soften
the eyes I'm a truck trying to squint
too much steer best
read till the other way mate and chin up
gorgeous kiss kiss kiss
like your thumb limit that's it
you know you like to spice boys like
there's something for everyone yet Amin
you know like the Spice boys yeah I mean
you want some with hit with here you go
on you know you want to be two
dark-skinned you go on like you wanted
me to go to you don't I mean there's a
bit of texture there's everything
a little bit closer there's a nice
little pocket of light there back there
sup here all right give me the motion
that you're walking and slightly overlap
your feet a little bit
that's it hand the pockets both of them
yeah it's awesome add hold there
yeah okay now go close and bring it
actually do it again that was cute
that's okay but this turbo tie for the
front is funny
okay I'll look at mom and dad Oh add
Sedona or look at mom and dad
yeah that's it now mom and dad I want a
bit of passion I want you to kiss yeah
that's better all right guys when you
ready walk out now go for it yeah yeah
beautiful
so no small nice mom yeah just Rhys off
oh don't make me jealous don't you
so sit down here then lay down and your
shoulders here and then your head right
back
your foreheads touching and you're
looking into each other that's it and
dad I want to give a big kiss there and
as you look at each other
dad closer closer that's it we're
laughing we're lovely we're kissing
yeah
give her a cute little kiss in the
temple that night and she's got a chin
up and is giggling man shut up Delhi
beautiful guys
until your faces in cause a gap all
right that's beautiful that's it perfect
just there and now turn your face into
hers they're closing gap that's just it
turn your face into her looking looking
into it stop there and eyes on me dying
eyes at me right here
so no smile just beautiful that's it and
now snuggling into your man snuggle in
writing to you man that's it yeah that's
beautiful
come on where are you where are you
where are you where are you where's your
the one the other one that looks like
they're driving
that's it beautiful loving that I want
you looking see with it that helicopter
is okay see I do this after you get
something look at and then you're
looking into her and you're loving it
chin up telling chin up we're loving
each other and sit and we have the
streaker from behind that's a guy
that's it and bury your head right into
her mom or that's it you're not going
close your eyes
they're beautiful love that that's
gorgeous well you know what I want to
say anything big laugh guys big in love
now
and now Lenny everybody more towards me
that's it
it's a bit more so just give yourself
some breathing space there we go and
shoulders back I'll see a little bit of
so turn your face this way chin up a
little bit till now just breathe through
your mouth what happens when you breathe
through your mouth your lips look full
up it without pouting so everything
looks amazing and then sometimes they
get you to something about putting lips
together so and eyes at me gorgeous
that's perfect
lean towards me dice to be close and
stop it that's it perfect now bring your
faces together
I want all faces touching basically what
I'm saying see I'll make a more dog and
turn your face that one that's better
let up there beautiful you girls of
awesome
so girls no smile here just passive just
really beautifully soft that's perfect
looking at me girls
dad give her a kiss on the forehead
there and close your eyes darling a bit
of a giggle there mum's laughing is
nailed my mom that's it government one
more
and giggling and not paying attention to
these guys I want your foreheads
touching in your laughing and he got my
god we're getting married she's going
she's leaving me all right so you guys
look at each other guys they look at me
look at look at the girls but really
clutch tight tight tight and looking
into your daughter some last little
words of wisdom there
just talking to her ear that's it and
that's it chin down and eyes down
perfect
all right beautiful hole this vide that
is so beautiful with it and licking
yeah just a bit that's it's in your face
into him okay back to whisper in his ear
a little bit and chin up a little bit
yeah that's perfect
turn your body towards me bit more
perfect this hand like this softer
that's a beautiful lean this way and
look at your hand you're not dying
that's it and softly down perfect that
move eyes down darling
down down perfect
this hand just like this but I want to
send the gap that's it beautiful that's
it that's it gorgeous and chin down chin
down and no smile now just really soft
really sexy beautiful
because your I stop are you blink for
more
gorgeous that was beautiful
girls as you walk again walk very slow
but don't look at me look at each other
to fun and you guys do the same give me
a second
okay walk this way
slower have some fun go boy
I want you to snuggle up to her but I
want you to both close your eyes and uh
this sounds funny I want you to pretend
like your faces are two cats purring on
each other you know what a cat sitter
walks up and rubs it sort of body on
your leg your faces are now the cats
close your eyes and turn your face
towards this way darling just sit and
now just snuggle up to make go for a
close your eyes both of you there you go
yeah keep going guys snuggling a little
bit gorgeous you know what if I was
close enough I'd hug you both right now
I'll be looking myself in the mirror all
day if I was you but can you take
pictures you're hot but can you take
pictures no bring it up up a little bit
higher sweetie your other right your
right elbow yeah so bring it further
outside so I can see your whole hand but
but bring it to the bit this way bit
more there you go that's it just there
yeah they go perfect and let me just get
rid of this one
that's gorgeous sweetie hold it there
that move eyes lower that's awesome
that's good I'll do them and hold it
she couldn't go to hear more perfect
it's like I just said I'm just gonna get
my hair color the same as the banister
go for a kiss both you close your eyes
kiss right on the lips and close your
eyes close your eyes guys really
important here for you to fall
chin down if you can and I was getting
heavy bring up that thing a bit higher
and bring your face just over it that's
it
chin down eyes down eyes down Dali you
know I'm just thinking whether we even
just put a towel underneath our necks so
it's sort of it lifts her turn your face
towards me dying
that's it and chin up a bit more that's
it yeah I need it on it's sort of
organized bit disheveled that's it now
turn your face gently to this way
towards the light
she never be dying that's perfect yes
yes yes so just hold my belt
close your eyes gorgeous chin up arch
your back that's it actually that was
perfectly hot your back
I need a dark background otherwise not
going to work so let's go where the
trees are
I'll get you here let's just a flash you
are gonna get soaked there's a large
shot of the day it'll look at each other
without passion in this photograph it's
just going to be nothing at all I need
you to look at each other like you
figured you're hungry and you're each
other's meals alright look at each
other's lips I want your perfectly front
on and then with a backward with flash
and as soon as we get it we're done okay
all I need is your faces now bring it
here behind your ears beautiful I want
you to face each other now and hold it
till it really close your hands chest
there darling and that right hand down
down now come see how John is closer to
me than you come closer towards me
stop now I want you to lean both of you
lean this way
stop that's it beautiful
now chin down a touch slight touch
running but don't tilt your head towards
me that's it leaning closer stop it look
at each other's lips guys now that's it
now bring your hand up hiya darling
that's it
chin down gorgeous turn your face
towards we made us a little bit stop go
closer together hanging it guys chin
down gorgeous - tilt your head away free
right hold it
I look for ambience ambience as in the
existing life authority around I expose
for that ambience and then I add my
light in the foreground so I need
glorified light holders who would like
to it perfect perfect and the gentleman
and then the two ladies there as well if
you can all come out this way you didn't
think you'd be seeing bubbles backlit
with flashes today did you all right so
you got a hole the lights you guys are
going to get married all right a
fantastic cuddle up nice and close so
we'll do a similar shot this time but I
want your bangs behind your ears and all
right so cuddle up nice and close now
what you guys are going to do you got to
come over here and you're going to blow
like you've never blown before that was
that was nothing I didn't mean anything
by that I'm just blow bubbles is what
I'm talking about okay but you need to
sort of actually uh I need you to get on
your knees and blow upwards okay okay so
over here now go behind them over here
all over here all over here yeah yeah
come in here all right now everyone so
you guys go like knee to knee like
shoulder to shoulder and you're gonna
stare you out and then blow the bubbles
upwards okay and come a little bit this
way and I need you to hold the flash for
me so what did you do you get these
ready right we're not playing for fun
here there's a thousand people in the
room here what's wrong with you people
you're going to run out of bubbles
that's it and how much could you beat
more behind them as well because I need
you i need your yell either flash
I need the flash to hit behind there as
well so everyone come nice and close and
probably come past this point they won
this way yep so everyone so bass up blow
the bubbles look at each other
bubbles bubbles more bubbles so I want
to see more bubbles here guys twist
towards me twist them who says it okay
so more here more here yeah here here
please don't Instagram this alright hold
it there how do they guys hold it says
she awesome oh my god have a look at
this shot that's freaky
really
good
young
what
Oh
use your feelings
move